well the EU has promised 800 million
dollars to Greece to deal with a refugee
and migrant surge from Turkey
that's after turkey said it will allow
hundreds of thousands of people to pass
through Greece and Bulgaria have stepped
up security on their side of the land
border with Turkey the Greek Coast Guard
is now actively repelling boats trying
to get to its islands across the eastern
Mediterranean root on Curtis decision to
open the borders breach is an agreement
it made with the EU in 2016 to resettle
refugees and stop them from crossing
into Europe turkey now hosts around 4
million refugees and says it cannot cope
with any more people fleeing the latest
violence in Eid l'p john psaropoulos
joins me now live from the Greek island
of Lesbos John I believe just in the
last hour the Greek PM has spoken what's
he had to say the Greek Prime Minister
stressed the need for a common Asylum
policy it's what been one of his main
causes in the European Union since he
came to power eight months ago he said
that we have not used our time wisely
since the last refugee crisis the time
has come for us to do this we need to
show we are sharing the burden
effectively and to show innovation we
cannot leave the burden pushed on to the
sole shoulders of external EU Member
States this is a cry of help from
Europe's Mediterranean coast that the
external border countries cannot be
gatekeepers to Europe without solidarity
and support from the rest of the
continent let's listen to what he had to
say this is a blatant attempt by Turkey
to use desperate people to promote this
geopolitical agenda and to divert
attention from the horrible situation in
Syria
the tens of thousands of people who try
to enter Greece over the past few days
did not come from it live they have been
living safely in Turkey for a long
period of time most of them speak
Turkish fluently and Europe will not be
blackmailed by Turkey over the refugee
issue Sean you're on the island of
lesbos we've seen a steady
stream of people arriving there over the
past few days is that continuing or is
it showing signs of slowing down yes it
is and the reason we're standing here at
the passenger port is that just moments
ago there was a police operation to
clear away some dozens of Afghan young
men who were trying to climb this fence
behind me and get onto that ferry which
is leaving for Athens shortly the police
just swept the area clean they've chased
people up into the hills it shows you
and we saw earlier similar scenes how
badly these people want to get off the
island move further inland move on to
the Greek mainland cross over into the
other parts of Europe and begin their
lives a lot of these young men are in
their teens they haven't finished school
many of them have dreams of going to
university becoming engineers becoming
doctors they want to follow careers
their families have sacrificed land or
savings to send them here on their own
because they can't all afford to come
over and this is their chance this is
their one chance to make something of
themselves and to save their families
but the harsh reality however is that on
the European side the onslaught of the
numbers is seen as overwhelming and you
can see the desperation through the
number of regimes that exist here in
Greece alone there are the people who've
been crossing over for five years who've
been allowed to apply for asylum in the
normal manner there's a second category
of people who applied for asylum since
January 1st when a new asylum law took
effect here in Greece and they are being
fast-tracked and they're supposed to be
processed in two months they've been
given priority because this is part of
an effort to increase the number of
returns of rejected asylum seekers
so those deportees can be sent back to
Turkey quickly and now there's a new
regime since Turkey opened its borders
on February 27th of people who won't be
considered for asylum at all and those
people are now being kept twenty yards
away from me behind this fence in the
port area they're going to be shipped
back to Athens tomorrow where tolls or
it isn't a final plan it is the
intention of the Greek authorities to
keep them in detention and not to give
them a chance to apply for asylum
because they're considered part of a
Turkish policy that is against Europe
rather than as people who crossed over
as free individuals thank for that
that's john psaropoulos there live from
lesbos ruby is ila is a refugee law
specialist at the University of Reading
he joins us now live from Redding good
to have you on the program uh the EU
Commission's president von der Leyen
said that the EU will give Greece all of
the support it needs in terms of what's
happening at Greece's border with Turkey
but Greece says we just heard there is
continuing to turn people back so what
should we take from that message of
support what does the EU actually likely
to do in real terms to help these people
yeah so so the prime minister of Greece
said something that is correct which is
that since the refugee crisis in 2015
Europe has has not come together to form
a policy of responsibility sharing that
alleviate some of the burden that
otherwise disproportionately falls on
frontier states such as Greece and Italy
there was a emergency relocation scheme
that was going to read out get about a
hundred and twenty thousand people from
both Italy and Greece and even those
places haven't fully been met and no
permanent scheme has been put in place
so he's absolutely right that the
European Union hasn't stepped to the
plate and and and doesn't yet seem to be
doing so he is course wrong that the
consequence is that if somebody is
seeking protection in Greece which is a
member of the European Union and bound
by a law then they can be on that basis
turn away and so and so the European
Commission's president may be willing to
provide Greece with financial support
with border guards but that's not
actually what Greece and what refugees
need what is needed is a European
greement for genuine solidarity and
responsibility sharing across the EU and
that is that is really the mission of
the European Commission if it wants to
genuinely help Greece radizen rather
than help Greece fend off refugees
let's want to come back to their point
you you made our I remember covering in
Brussels at the time when the that EU
plan was agreed on that I think 130,000
people would be resettled from Italy and
Greece there was so much fanfare at the
time why hasn't that been implemented
why hasn't that worked out well the
reality is there was first of all a
genuine resistance from several European
Union states to the resolution for the
reset for the relocation itself so
Hungary the Czech Republic Slovakia and
Poland have said initially they're not
gonna cooperate and that has even led
the European Commission to launch a
infringement proceedings against them in
the European Court of Justice
afterwards other European countries
which have nominally said they'll
cooperate have really been very sluggish
in offering relocation spaces in their
in their countries and so what was
supposed to happen very quickly and and
and for ultimately a fairly small
moderate number if we compare it to 3.7
million refugees that are in Turkey so
we were talking about a hundred and
twenty thousand people across the
continent or a European Union region of
over 500 million people what was
supposed to happen fairly quickly and
rapidly hasn't actually fully
materialized where some people relocated
but the numbers haven't reached 120,000
over a course of a couple of years and
then the attempt to use that basis of
the emergency relocation scheme to
create a permanent basis for relocating
refugees across the European Union on an
equitable basis that takes into account
GDP per capita unemployment the capacity
of countries to absorb refugees etc
that's AB scheme that was proposed has
effectively been stalled coming
the last European parliamentary
elections and it hasn't been resurrected
since thank you for your analysis that's
rubies I've lo there a refugee law
specialist at the University of Reading
thank you